when we set out to plan out this
semester course okay and if you have
your course outline there um it's not
necessary but if you have it down winner
of fetch wait a second
um I literally thought out okay what are
all the cool maths things that we just
never get time to look at or they're not
really related very clearly to other
parts of masse do or it's very hard to
uh to write a test for for certain
things and so if you can't assess it you
can't really do it as a topic and that's
not just math that's for your subjects
okay so I laid out those ten sort of
topics I said look these are really cool
I would love to do these but the problem
with doing that is that they're kind of
all armed they're all disconnected and
random right and one of the one of the
best ways to confuse someone is just to
give someone a bunch of random
disconnected things that have no order
or secrets to them it's just like here
you go or have fun and I don't expect
you remember any of this okay so I've
thought very long and hard about how to
string these together in a way that
makes sense okay so where do we begin
what was our first topic it was beauty
of mathematics right the reason why I've
started there is because come and the
theme of this course is to think deeply
about simple things right and I think
the reason why this was a great place to
start is because the things we looked at
were both very very familiar right
they're things we've seen before things
like um things like architecture and
parts of the green body all those kinds
of things between it kind of uses a
given but familiar but it's also
surprising the kinds of things that we
discovered it was kind of like ah really
right there's more to these simple
things than first meets the eye that's
why that was what we do now secondly
after Pete of ethics the last stop in or
we just fish was fractals and the reason
why is because I think fractals are one
of the best examples of beautiful shapes
that are generated mathematically but
also occur you know in nature is like
that for Julia we looked at our rivers
in ferns and galaxies and all these
kinds of things which exhibit is right
and I broke it off as a separate sub
topic because you could spend a lot of
time with
well now that then leads us to the
question of where do you go from here
what do you think you have a look at the
tapas that are laid out there right what
do you think would be the next natural
step okay now I kind of think what I
think fractals right you know we would
use some of these it took a long time
but I think fractals
I think infinity I think of things that
repeat on it on forever right that's the
whole thing that makes a practice
tractable right so okay I'd really like
to do the topping which I think I called
it math era you don't know what your
calculator tells you it's something I
can find things like infinity right so
infinity is what I wanted to get to I
know that's kind of a natural next step
from fractals okay however the
mathematics on infinities plural it
needs some groundwork laid before we get
to it okay
he's kind of a the illustration I would
you I think that's a bit like tourism I
think matters a bit like tourism it's
about going and seeing cool basic things
of learning how they'll fits together
and how it works and what's interesting
okay high school you get six years right
to go on a tour and because it's over
six years you've got all these other
things to learn you only get to look at
so many things right so what we're doing
is we're going off the beaten track
looking at some places you would never
discover otherwise but just like in your
life tourism if you want to travel to
get around you need some language right
if you want to go and look at these
things you need to learn new languages
it's going to describe these things the
biggest most important piece of language
is lots of them right each one has its
own language but the biggest one for
infinities is our next topic which is
set theory okay now you're like really
that's that's yeah really trust me we're
gonna get there